I'm honest I'm going to stick with d4 I
think teen night is someone who's been
following the Anand gelfand and I'm very
happy that there's a rest day in that
tournament tomorrow pinned devoting
quite a bit of time to trying to get
that content out so it's nice to have a
little rest day for them and me Knight
c3 nims Oh Indian yes we're gonna have
names Oh Indian land um push it before
yes sir Queen see to classical line yeah
I'm going to go with this I could
definitely use a refresher on it I know
I covered it the one game i posted a
victor Laz nikka playing the white side
I really liked how ya followed up in
that game let's go with a three that's
why you play Queen c2 ok so what just
happened
what just happened there what just
happened was well have the bishop hair
if I play Bishop here there's night here
isn't there no that's not working out
just yet Bishop here night here takes
takes I take this pun so hmm let's get
my bishop out i think that that was the
move that was played and i think
bringing the Queen back will eventually
be needed here I really do need to get
this move in and I might be okay with
just giving that dark square Bishop back
up just to get some more time in I might
transition from I might look at it as
like you know what instead of me hanging
on to the bishop pair let me try and
show that you know I have a good center
instead this move however hmm i guess
it's prepping see five or something I
need more development here definitely
need more development but Queen here III
night you two to see three i think is
what was played hmm III first i do that
that's not good let's get this guy in
let's get them in there need my light
square Bishop to come out it's not going
to be so easy though this bishops going
to put pressure on this pond if I bring
my bishop out to deed through i'll be
needing to play my night here and i
don't know if i want to do that however
can i start to build up a center and
actually hang on in my dark square
Bishop now i think if i play f3c five is
a nice way to strike
hmm what about Bishop e2 to f3 if night
here I still have Bishop takes Queen and
then Bishop takes pawn night here let me
just make sure that night here takes
Knight takes Queen Bishop takes pawn I'm
up a pond and the night doesn't have any
peace it can be taken but if I play here
would have a piece that can be taken but
my bishop isn't going to get trapped or
anything yeah I should just get out of
it before it's too late yeah let's get
out of that get out of it now Bishop
here right it's got to be played I guess
I could be reinforcing my deep on with
my rook at some point i'm looking i'm
still for some reason fixated on night e
2 2 c 3 as a reorganization my pieces
i'm going to try that but i think i'm
still following at least on the white
end moves that were played out of that
game i might want to just cash in though
I got to go quick here if I back up
there's g5 and then there's this maybe
that could be okay hang on would they
really weaken their King side would they
really hmm I need more development I
have the bishop pair but so what I'm not
liking that I'm not fully developed here
there we go alrighty well rook d1 let's
get this in pressure on g2 that's a pain
could take and maybe grab this pun this
has to be a little uncomfortable for
black right and I can't go too far away
we're gonna see let's go night and again
this is an issue maybe oh you know what
okay maybe I can be pushing here take
with my rook I think that that's best
pressure on d6 maybe that's ah now I can
maybe target this rook here Queen here
Bishop here this is still uncomfortable
though there might be a pawn push as
well my night is pinned after pawn push
I can only take with the pond not the
night so getting my queen off of that I
think is a good idea Queen d2 we may be
back home even avoiding night c5 to be
three or nightly for tricks tough to say
about a minute advantage for black but I
do have the pressure on this guy how do
I complete my development whoa let's see
Queen here my rook might be a close to
trapped or something maybe Queen just
home bring the Queen home is she too
good for her home
no she's not let's just come home Queen
let's just come home d 6 I don't even I
don't know if I even want to take that
if Queen here takes rook here I'm really
running scared yeah this is scary town
scary town I don't want to take that pun
ha I don't want to take them no no no no
no no I want to push that night away you
know what I give up that pun I want to
get play on this G file maybe play
something like f4 okay now I could
castle just in the nick of time not
something off to stare out for a little
bit I have less than 40 less than 40 and
I'm in trouble definitely in trouble
right here might have a going back and
forth here knight c6 to e5 I need I need
a granola bar I think I feel a granola
bar coming out here especially with that
tournament coming up soon need a granola
bar i'm down on time I need a I need
some water I'm out running low on water
here I need uh hydrate don't need to be
passing out on my birthday Jess streamer
passes out during stream that's a great
headline right there everybody wants to
read that tomorrow morning chess
streamer passes out on his birthday on
twitch Oh knight c6 okay less than a
minute I'm feeling a little more
comfortable 96 okay looking to pile up
on this this pond here I think I do this
it's weakening but so what I have
control over the center this has to be
uncomfortable but it's no longer
uncomfortable no longer comfortable i'm
just going to take them out and then
neutralize the light square Bishop have
my queen replace
oh I should consider night to be five I
could still do that though the bishop
has to take otherwise the this rook will
be misplaced on the B file thing I just
defend with the b3 I should have
definitely considered night b5 am i
doing huh Oh forks I have that square
available less than 20 I must I just
lost track of time right there have a
good thing Queen here I take with the
tempo on the Queen Queen here i take i
push here first maybe if i move my
brooke away oh now i'm on the queen um
let's just back up push that night away
and then f6f six now it's coming
together I'm out of seven it's guard c4
let's give a check push this pond get
rid of that night get rid of them um no
no no no no no right here oh i just
spent so much time right there it spent
so much time take a night push up on
time burners where are you time burners
where's the main threat anything
anything anything anything anything
anything anything anything anything oh I
so need a granola bar right now okay
good game oh man I was trying to just
win objectively what is the matter with
you quit trying to win objectively just
burn burn time burn burn time ah good
game ah
let me back up let's flip that forward T
night tough game as usual classical line
of the NIMS o Indian and I think that
grabbing the Jeep on it's probably a
good idea I really like this move by
black I really like it I think it shows
a really nice understanding of the game
right here not trying to let's say make
an awkward move like rook c6 and just go
on the defensive what is rook c6 allow
me to do just complete my development a
move that I already played but you know
there's definitely as far as I could
tell going to be compensation if I grab
that pot after Queenie 727 if I run with
rook takes rook here eventually there's
you know this open file that's you know
under blacks control my rook is nowhere
to be found in such a position my
bishops still sitting at the home square
and if I move it a little bit later then
this pawn gets sniped I don't know
that's it seems way too risky to go grab
that pond right there so instead i
offered upon hoping for Bishop takes and
then maybe I could get some play over
here with f4 and then I don't know maybe
trying to exploit this pin that that
would have to be well I think it would
be a little bit uncomfortable for black
if the bishop takes the pond but that
would have been pretty interesting
instead I think we're already in a time
scramble at this point I should have
considered [ __ ] or a night b5 the
lightscribe it shows come off and this
is the right thing to do when there's
tension between these guys you question
is it better to keep the tension or not
in this case it's not because I'm ready
to displace this rook this is where it
belongs in this file so don't just get
shifted off of that to make a recapture
on b7 ah so yeah well I mean we make
mistakes right here definitely we're
just moving about and
bullet mode both of us and that's it
already good game as usual t night